for a few seconds the launch from
wallops island off the coast of virginia
seemed to be normal then something went
wrong
an explosion and the Antares rocket
started falling back to earth
it's a serious setback for orbital
science the private company that built
and operated the rocket it was carrying
a Cygnus cargo capsule bound for the
International Space Station it's a tough
time to lose a launch vehicle like this
and its payload it's not as tragic as
losing a life associated with it and so
we're very happy to report that there
were no injuries and the safeguards both
in flight and on the ground worked as
they should have the six astronauts
currently aboard the space station will
have to live without the fresh supplies
the sickness was carrying but nASA says
it's not a problem the station's in
great shape the crews in good shape
we've got plenty of work for them to do
on orbit and plenty of supplies on orbit
to keep them going for quite some time
happen however the loss of the 150
million euro mission is an embarrassment
for America's space program just hours
after the explosion a Russian rocket
successfully took off also carrying
supplies for the space station